welcome back to the D show
I'm with no stranger to the show so I'm
late going fast and furious here in the
house people who let me bring him up to
speed so at one point people know Paul
Walker mmm and you walk did you actually
if people go back and watch the show we
did you actually got in a really bad car
accident
yeah your former Muslim turned atheist
came back to Islam and then there was a
point your life where you actually were
you watching fast and furious you know I
probably did yeah probably they looking
back yeah and then you had that car
accident yeah and you went through the
struggles that many people are go
through and we're still struggling it's
a struggle this life is you know that's
my first question I guess tell us what
do you see now you're an imam a
spiritual leader you run the College of
Islamic Studies what do you see
people come in your office what are some
of the major a few of the major
challenges crisis's that you see young
people old people going through there
the biggest thing is that crisis of
faith right now I think people don't
know why they're Muslim anymore and
they're not sure if you know if if this
is if this is for them they're trying to
figure out you know many people what
they're doing unfortunately is they're
trying to be fulfilled through religion
rather than realizing that religion or
Islam is something that you're supposed
to fulfill a purpose or mission that
Allah is set up for it's a test life is
a test what happens is if you feel that
Islam is there to fulfill you and you
give in charity and you help out in
order to make you feel good the moment
you stop feeling good the moment you go
through some difficulty or challenge or
some problem that happened in the Masjid
or some Muslim friend you know made fun
of you whatever it is you find the text
that you can't understand you all of a
sudden start backing away and you start
going away from this religion and I feel
a lot of people are going through that
they're going through a lot of questions
they don't know the answers to them and
they just start running away and they
think that there's no answers out there
there's they don't know who to talk to
you know so that's one of the challenges
that people are going through you know
another challenge is just literally
people not people not having a good
solid Islamic education so what happens
is you know almost everyone in my
community or the people that I see it's
very common Muslims will generally go
through university they have to have at
least a four-year degree if not a
master's degree so we're talking about
you know 16 years of education but very
little religious education their
religious education is like you learn
how to read Arabic you learn a little
bit how to read the Quran then you throw
a party and you say you this guy just
learned how to read the Quran and that's
it you've graduated you've learned
everything you need to know about Islam
and that's it and when you go into
university you go into college you take
classes on philosophy you take class on
psychology you encounter all these
different theories you know Sigmund
Freud Immanuel Kant you know Nietzsche
all these things and it messes with your
head and it makes you start questioning
things that you don't have a foundation
to even come up with an Islamic answer
to so do you recommend what do you
recommend when somebody in university
you have that philosophy class yeah I
mean I'm I'm very honest and I'm telling
people that if you don't have a solid
Islamic foundation don't ever walk into
a philosophy class especially a
philosophy class and don't walk into any
Islamic Studies class that's taught from
a secular perspective it's gonna destroy
your understanding of Islam it's gonna
teach you how to what they call
deconstructing Islam and looking how it
evolved over time and they're kind of
presenting like a Christian evolution of
you know all these ideas on projecting
it onto Islam it's just gonna mess with
your head and people go in and they
think that you know they're gonna learn
something from this or you know they're
they're brave enough to you know
challenge their philosophy professors
who are hardcore atheists or maybe
agnostics and they've been thinking
about this and researching it for 30
years
you're literally you don't even know how
to swim you don't even know how to do a
back float and you're jumping into the
deep end of the water that's exactly
what's happening and I see people drown
all the time you get into a wrestling
match with a black belt in jujitsu that
that's that that's exactly what's
happening you think you're the Karate
Kid and that's it you know you're not
gonna karate chop that's right okay
so you actually you have overcome this
and you were an atheist you were very
well versed in atheism now you went to
debating atheists yes you've debated
many tell us how this is wrong yes so I
mean after doing a lot of research now I
have I know the arguments that they make
the modern atheist and what they call
the new atheist Richard Dawkins Sam
Harris all these guys and I know the old
atheists as well you know Immanuel Kant
and you know David Hume and Kant was not
an atheist but you know it's skeptic
David Hume and these type of penuche and
all that so the thing is I debate them
on a regular basis and I realized that
there's a few issues intellectually
rationally their arguments don't really
stand up and they see that but what's
happening is I notice in them there's
this intrinsic pessimism that they have
and it's emotional and they come up with
emotional arguments you know well you
know it gets down to they had some bad
experience in life they went through
some trauma they had a bad experience at
church with their religion whatever it
was and you see that emotional thing
coming out and you say well what
happened to all that intellectual
rationalism that you were talking about
when they complain about why there's so
many bad things happening in the world
they make it all emotional I say you're
supposed to be that intelligent person
so so from a rational intelligent
perspective they don't win any of these
debates and you can see that there's
some internal psychological trauma going
on there and now I can see it very
clearly because III deal I studied the
psychology of that I deal with people
regularly on a regular basis do
counseling and all that and also I deal
with these intellectual arguments so
when you got these Islamic understanding
and Islamic arguments for existence of
God why religion you know why why Islam
you know came what why is there purpose
in life how do we rationalize that it's
just clear as daylight now I want you to
tell us about the God hot spot that
everyone is has been wired as proof to
this when we come back we're gonna go
and find out more about it don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
back here on the D show with Sheikh
Mustafa tell us now it's actually now
they done studies that belief is
something that is innate yes and
fighting against it is something that is
acquired you have to like fight against
your nature that's like this gas pot is
put put in you this is correct yeah
absolutely I mean they've done research
out of the universities and in England
is Oxford they did a major study and
they found out that people are naturally
inclined towards this and and the reason
why it is this is the way our minds are
structured the same way that you know we
talk about scientific proof scientific
evidence our minds are structured to
accept that when an experiment goes one
way ninety nine times and one way the
other time you say well we're going to
go with we're gonna believe that it's
this way the one time must have been a
mistake ninety nine times the experiment
was able to repeat itself that's the
scientific method so that's why people
are very strong about believing in
science the same thing when we talk
about this idea of causality cause and
effect that we see when we think about
things and we say well what's the origin
of this entire universe
all these planets everything that exists
what's the what's the origin of all the
complexities our digestive system all
the systems and how they function
together and everything it's natural
it's it's built within us it's built
into us that we're gonna make a
conclusion so you know what if there is
a creation there's a creator it didn't
just pop out of nowhere it doesn't make
sense all of a sudden you know you find
something very complex and you say maybe
you know that iPhone that we see maybe
the wind blew it and you know just metal
pieces kind of randomly formed together
somehow so it's naturally built in
because that's the way we're designed to
think and that's what we call in Islam
to fit through the natural disposition
that God created us upon so in order for
you to go against that right to
disbelief in God and say you know what I
don't believe that God exists or some of
that you have to go against your innate
nature and it actually takes like a leap
of faith to get to that level
there's a professor Pascale Boyer from
the Washington University he talks about
for our cognitive senses that disbelief
that belief is generally the path of
resistance collaborate on meds that's
just not the meaning that's natural yeah
I mean if you just if you think about
children you know the same thing one of
the early scholars in my folklore Deena
Rosie he says you know if you take a if
you take a rock and you kind of throw it
to the side and a little child is there
he'll look around to see where did this
rock come from this is built in we want
we want to investigate we want to find
out what's going on that's exactly what
this professor is saying professor boy
is saying the exact same thing it's
built within us we have this natural
desire to question things to get to the
bottom of things to try to understand
them and when we do that it
automatically inclines us to believe in
something which makes sense and that's
belief in God belief in God believe that
there's a creator it makes sense so
that's exactly what he's talking about
now you know a lot of people get as you
say stumped you know this is an
intellectual this guy has his ph.d and
he's coming out and then one argument
they say well like you had brought up do
you believe in two fairies
Santa Claus and you know of course not
of course not then they put the Creator
in that same category how do you go
ahead and refute that see the thing is
it's it's a it's a deceptive argument
because you know what there are people
who believe in strange things that don't
have any basis so just because there are
people who believe in that and they
maybe also believe in God you don't
throw the baby out with the bathwater as
they say right so yeah there are they're
all four there are a lot of false
religions out there doesn't mean that
all religions are wrong because the ones
that you happen to come across we're
wrong right so this is not the way that
we function you know if someone has some
bad qualities in them it doesn't mean
that they're all bad and if someone has
some good qualities in them it doesn't
mean that they're all good
right so this is not the way we make
judgments so this is what people do is
they start going in so they start making
fun and they say you know what see this
guy they believe in this they believe in
that they're all tricked and confused so
you have to differentiate between what
are good rational beliefs that people
hold and what are bad ones so if you
encounter a believer for example someone
who believes in God but then believes
that if you break a mirror you get seven
years of bad luck
it doesn't mean that all of a sudden
because he believes in
idea about bad luck which doesn't really
have much basis all of a sudden because
of that belief his belief in God must
also be incorrect see we don't judge the
truth based upon what people believe
this was a statement of a well-known
Muslim his name was Ali he was a fourth
caliph in Islam he said don't know the
truth based upon what people are saying
know the truth yourself and then you're
gonna know the people who follow that
truth and I think there's a lot to that
and what many atheists do is they try to
focus and make fun of people they have
you know movies making fun of look at
how funny these Christian preachers are
and they're doing weird things and all
of that stuff that doesn't negate the
fact that belief in God is something
rational it's something that you can you
can you know be convinced of it it makes
sense to the average human mind
you can't lump everything together and
just cause that to confuse people
now the confused respected skeptic also
now because maybe they don't have that
solid foundation you can usually as you
grow in knowledge your Iman girls you
can see through a lot of this deception
that's out there but maybe someone now
is confused because all they see
nowadays and it seems like the the media
is it's it's a it's magic right you you
you get sucked in and you start to
believe some of the things out there
maybe you're Muslim also and you think
how could this Islam be the truth that
my parents are pushing on me when all it
is associated with violence Isis all day
at night an oppression of women what do
you say yeah I mean that the first thing
people need to judge Islam not based
upon what they see in the media first of
all I mean they need to understand that
the media has an agenda it's it's a
for-profit industry they have an agenda
and what they're gonna report is has to
be sensational news so that's the first
thing whenever we see something in the
media we should be very skeptical and we
should say wait wait a minute
do they have some agenda behind why
they're promoting something like that
and then the second thing is you know
when you're a little bit skeptical it's
good to be a little bit skeptical on
these things say I want to find out the
truth so how do you find out the truth
you go to the sources or you go to
people who know the sources and you say
hey why don't you answer you know I saw
that they
was mistreatment of women going on in
such in such country is that
representative of the religion of Islam
go and ask a scholar and he'll tell you
and explain to you what is Islam really
say about women go and check the Quran
and see what it talks about women
there's an entire chapter you know
labeled chapter number 4 is about women
titled women so if you look at what what
status Islam is actually given to women
and you look at some of these practices
that people are doing and you'll find
that they're actually antithetical
they're actually in contradiction with
the real teachings of Islam you find out
that Islam is a solution to these
problems there are Muslims who will do
bad things the same way there are there
are Christians there are Buddhists there
are Hindus and there are atheists that
do very bad things
we don't judge people's religion based
upon what people are doing
you judge people's religion based upon
that religion itself so you do you apply
the same standards to the religion of
Islam you learn about Islam you read
about Islam you read the Quran you read
the other texts on Islam you learn what
it's LOM says and then you can judge
whether that those Muslims that you see
on TV or whoever else you see if they're
in line with the teachings of religion
or a religion of Islam or not we're
gonna be right back
willing with the not the million dollar
question the billion dollar question
here on the D show don't go anywhere
back here on the D show thank you for
tuning in again if you haven't
subscribed subscribe right now so you
get the next show delivered directly to
you I said the not the million dollar
question but this is the billion dollar
question every human being should be
asking themselves
I mean we're functioning in this earth
we live you know newborn child's are
coming in old people young people are
leaving but people are just engrossed in
accumulating more wealth more money you
know living the party and die Yolo you
only live once but they're forgetting
the billion dollar question why am I
here what's the purpose yeah and I've
asked many people have you ever asked
yourself this question and I just get
astonished that you know - now it's not
a surprise anymore but in the beginning
it was people don't ask that simple
question yeah I mean I I think that
people have probably asked it
when they were young at some point in
time but they just kind of covered it up
they couldn't find an answer to it
quickly you know we want everything
quick transfer fast foods fast
instant coffee everything is just got to
be done quickly so everyone they think
about that question you know most people
think about it and then they just
dismiss it I didn't come up with a quick
answer I talked to my friend and you
know someone just came up with something
weird and you say okay whatever you know
so the thing is we had to ask the
ultimate question you know many people
are redefining this idea of the purpose
of life it's not just what you want to
do in life it's not your career there
it's being filled with what your career
is with what this is there's an ultimate
purpose in life and that purpose in life
is that we're here to worship God to
adjust our lives in according to the
guidance that God has given us now
someone says look I got to work I got to
provide for my family I got to go play
some ball what are you talking about do
you want me to be stuck in a mosque all
day worshipping what do you actually me
exactly so worship needs to be defined
clearly worship in Islam doesn't mean
that you're engaged in prayer all the
time it doesn't mean that you give up
your job you quit your job and you
become a monk and you sit in a cave
somewhere and you know you're just
remembering God all the time
worship in Islam basically means that
you're adjusting your lifestyle in your
life according to the way that God
wanted it so God knew he made this world
where you got to work you got to spend
time with your family you got to
socialize you got to do all these things
but when you're doing them you're doing
it in a moral way in a way that's
righteous in line with the teachings
that it that God actually wanted us to
apply so we're not gonna steal we're not
gonna cheat we're not gonna you know
abuse our family we're not gonna back
buy and talk bad about other people
we're not gonna gossip these type of
things is what we call worship in Islam
it's it's a holistic program for how we
live our life in every single thing that
we do knowing that God is watching and
that we will be held accountable you
know after this life in terms of what we
did in this life that kind of goes
opposite let's say you're an atheist I
mean there are some good people who call
themselves humanists I mean because it's
part of also that nature to be good to
be then you get corrupted you you read a
book like Machiavellian mm-hmm and now
you
you want more money so now you're
promoting or learning to lie deceive and
we've seen a lot of that whatever
benefits you yeah not that that's become
this selfish individualism is becoming
very very common and your even people
who initially they say no no I'm gonna
follow good values it's very tempting
and there's nothing to keep you in check
if all of a sudden you know someone puts
a hundred dollar bill in front of you
you say you know would you would you
take that no one else is watching you
don't believe anyone's watching you
don't believe any one's gonna hold you
accountable you think you're gonna get
away with it
it's tempting and you say no no I can
resist make it $1,000 make it $10,000
it starts to get more and more tempting
right what's gonna hold you back from
doing that if you don't actually have
something if you don't have a purpose in
life where it's gonna help keep you in
check and make you realize that you're
gonna have to stand in front of God's
one day and you're gonna have to account
for everything that you've done in this
life including that money that you took
or including that lie that you told
you'll be so surprised people used to
play a game called what would you do for
a million and everything just went all
morals and everything just went out the
window people selling their soul they'll
sell their mothers that's it yeah
life is disabled you're on that debt
foundation of connection of purpose with
your Creator your living purpose would
you say that now these things you're
you're less likely to get tempted by
these things absolutely as long as you
keep it in mind you know the more
conscious you are of Godding the more
conscious you are of your purpose in
life you always remember that you know
what you know you you learn to restrain
yourself and you learn to remember that
not only you're going to be held
accountable but you develop things you
know we fast is Muslims we fast in
Ramadan we learned that level of
self-control so when you give up some
food for a while you'll give up water in
the summer he's hot you're thirsty you
want some water when you remember I gave
up water when I could have drank water
right you learn a different level of
self-discipline I can give up line I can
give up stealing I can give up cheating
I can give up these other things if I
learn to give up something where I had
to struggle against myself so there are
these spiritual practices which make us
stronger stronger believers and also
we're able to resist our own desires and
temptations that come our way
if someone so the person
was always saying okay what's the
purpose of life is to have a family
what's the purpose of life is to help
people is to help the poor to feed the
poor what's the purpose of life to win
the Nobel Peace Prize how do these all
fit in see the thing is we people need
to zoom out you know so this these are
these are some good things sometimes you
know helping your you know helping poor
people fighting for you know social
justice these are good things you know
but this is not an entire system or
program of why we were created in the
first place it must be a means this can
be a means this this can be one of the
many means that we have but what we need
to realize is that there's a predefined
purpose of our existence in terms of why
we came here
there's a reason God created us here for
a reason we need to figure out what is
that reason and the only way we can know
that we can't just sit and close our
eyes and sit in a cave and contemplate
I'll try and figure out you know why
we're here in the first place the only
way to know that is if God were you know
communicated to us and that's why we got
to read the revelation and we got to see
you know what God telling us why did he
create us and what are we supposed to be
doing here so that's all part of it
charity donation helping people the
Golden Rule reciprocating being nice to
people
that's all good that's part of it but
it's not all of it so you got to zoom
out and you got to see how all of that
fits together and that's what the
message of Islam is where's a good place
you know there's the few things that
usually desires blocks a person desires
you know the inherited beliefs from and
in the culture but you talk about right
now deep reflection contemplating how
can you before we leave motivate someone
where's a good place to start and how to
put these things because you know
Johnnie and Sally day to Friday is
coming up and you know she's got the VIP
access he's sitting back to the club
this other person you know same thing
he's hitting the pub and now they tuned
in and but where where before they go
back some motivation to get them I like
to mention def a lot yeah yeah I would
definitely reflect upon death you know
that more people think about death is
something certain something that
regardless of what religion you you
follow wherever you're coming from you
think about the fact everyone believes
that they're gonna die even those people
who think that you know they can freeze
their body and maybe someday science
will bring
them back or whatever reflect on death
and think about you know what what's
gonna happen after death you take it
more seriously and you start to reflect
you know what I want to know what
happens afterwards I should go and check
out a book on it's law I should go check
out the Quran see what it says in terms
of what's gonna happen after death how
we're gonna be responsible in this life
and that starts to wake you up there's
no coming back
some people have deceived like okay God
can just tell me if there is at when I
die like what was it all about so I can
go back and correct my mistakes see that
that will defeat the purpose of the test
yeah so it's the same thing if a teacher
gives you a test and all of a sudden you
make all these mistakes and you turn it
in and all of a sudden say you know what
we're gonna we're gonna go ahead and
give it back to you with all the right
answers now you go ahead and fill it in
what's the point of the test
there's no point so we get it when we
get one shot one shot at this line shot
right now is that that's it it's done
and you don't know when the test is
gonna be over so if you're thinking
about delaying if you're thinking about
you know I'll think about this tomorrow
you know I got a I got a I got a movie
to go watch I got a I got a coffee to go
drink I got to go hang out with my
friends you know you you can do all
those things could just cut it down take
a little bit of time before you go to
sleep every night read 30 minutes
reflect contemplate think about these
things take life a little bit more
seeing the Creator ask the Creator ask
the Creator just say pray for guidance
so you know what God show me the right
path and if you're sincere and you're
willing to put a little bit effort into
it he'll help you and he'll guide you
tell us you're the Dean of the College
of salami Studies Ellis if people want
to go ahead and start some classes with
you yes the College of Islamic Studies
is a full comprehensive Islamic
curriculum Islamic education program we
have our web site College Islam calm or
we offer 18 different courses which give
you a good balanced relevant
contemporary understanding of the
religion of Islam you can take courses
on site and you can take courses online
you can register at any time and you can
start those classes and benefit yourself
we started with please one with P Salaam
alaikum Salaam